a London landmark is being silenced Big
Ben will stop its famous chimes for
several years starting next Monday
extensive repairs are being made to the
famous clock tower that looms over the
Palace of Westminster the home of the
British Parliament trod Agra is at Big
Ben in London Charlie good morning good
morning well we've made it all the way
up the tower and that is the Bell better
known as Big Ben why service it now well
chief engineer said try running your car
24 hours a day for about a hundred and
sixty years but the idea of that staying
quiet for four years a British
politician said it's just bonkers the
big bones of the great Bell have echoed
across London for a hundred fifty seven
years of pretty much unbroken service
through six monarchs the kings and
queens who have come and gone right up
to Queen Elizabeth even the German
Luftwaffe couldn't stop the bells
tolling through the worst of the Blitz
Big Ben refused to stop work for a
second even if his hands did take a bit
but now time has taken its toll
and the deafening chimes the farm
workers who are not only giving London's
most famous face a facelift but
renovating the whole tower inside and
out like adding an elevator says
excitable architect Adam with Trotsky so
we're going to put a lift in we're going
to put a tee point in there's nowhere to
make a cup of tea up there at the moment
and we're going to put a toilet in as
well no toilets one thing but in this
country nowhere to make T is just
uncivilized the slave will move five
years ago we got a rare look inside the
belfry to see the huge Bell up close by
1854 they had to get this clock that was
the most accurate clock ever built he in
West worth the mechanic who's been
winding the clock literally for the past
seven years wants to keep it that way he
has an old-fashioned fix pennies while
putting on or taking off a penny on the
pendulum whether you speed up or slow
down the clock by two fifths of a second
in 24 hours not only is the old clock
still doing its job so is in West worth
because it's such a long stoppage period
we'll be able to check absolutely
everything on the clock I'm still
working it's good but Londoners and
tourists alike are little heartbroken
the city's most iconic landmark will be
out of action for so long Big Ben is Big
Ben and people want to see Big Ben not
have a been a full Ben that would
definitely be a bummer for sure to come
all the way here and
not to be able to see
and for those used to Big Ben's
comforting tolls for years of silence
will be deafening
now next Monday at noon will be the last
time the Big Ben will ring as usual
they're still going to use it for things
like New Year's Eve and Remembrance Day
which is kind of like our Memorial Day
the clock itself will show the time at
least on one of its faces throughout the
entire project Wow in London I'm gonna
need to plan a European vacation you
better do it this weekend before Monday
sees me even though it's not the same
thing they could create the sound yeah
yeah even though it's not Ben but I like
to that they're putting in an elevator
but after listening to Jordan we'd want
to take the stairs that's right we do
activities activity we'll build up our
games all right how great it's gonna
look when it's all done in four years